is it
true that it's like one of the most sold
books in history no okay i've heard this
kind of statement tom clancy book
comes out sells more than atlas shrugged
but our red
and i shouldn't say this but it's the
truth so i'll say it a very unscientific
study done
by the smithsonian institute probably in
the early 90s
that basically surveyed uh ceos
and i asked them what was the most
influential book on you
and adlershow came out as number two
the second most influential book in ceos
in in the country
but there's so many flaws in the study
one was it
you want to guess what the number one
book bible the bible but the bible was
like
you know so maybe they served a hundred
people i don't know what the exact
numbers were but let's say it's 100
people
and 60 said the bible and ten said atlas
shrug
and there were a bunch of books over
there so you know i don't
that's again the psychology discussion
what we're having exactly well and it's
it's one thing i've learned and maybe
covet has taught me and
and uh nobody you know they're very few
people who know how to
do statistics and almost nobody knows
how to think
probabilistically that is think in terms
of probabilities that it is a skill
it's a hard skill and everybody thinks
they know it so i see doctors thinking
their statisticians and giving whole
analyses of the data on covet and they
don't have a clue what they're talking
about not because they're not good
doctors
because they're not good statisticians
it's not
you know people think that they have one
skill and therefore it translates
immediately into another skill and it's
just not true
um so i've been astounded at how how bad
people are at that
you